all of the Ancients whether you're
talking about judeo-christian values or
or Greek philosophers all of them
believe to the happiness had to do with
the sense of moral purpose
the tension between Jerusalem and Athens
the interplay that is what built the
West that is what built the greatest
civilization in the history of mankind
[Music]
that was the difference definitionally
between agnostics and atheists right
right so if you want to say that if we
go about agnosticism and say maybe God
exists maybe doesn't but I don't have
evidence of it so I don't believe you
know that's that's borderline agnostic
atheist that's fine I mean it doesn't
really matter I mean to my central
argument whether you're an agnostic or
an atheist the bottom line is that
without the belief that there is a
purpose to the universe without a belief
that there is a purpose to your life
without a belief that you have the
capacity to make individual choices it's
very difficult to build the civilization
by difficult I mean impossible okay I
think free well by the way is the single
most important principle undergirding
any civilization okay
oh yeah your own life you're not because
you chose to come here and you chose to
ask me a question right I would hate to
think that the universe randomly imbued
you with a set of atoms that showed up
here randomly to ask me a question
that'd be very disappointing to me there
is a baseline level of debate retreat
for Christians on the cultural left it's
the same sort of thing that they've used
with regard to Jack Phillips over at
masterpiece cake shop really he hates
gay people it's not that he's a
Christian who believes he has to abide
by his religious standards is that he
secretly hates gay people and trans
people and he's just using religion as a
cover
they say the same sort of thing about
Mike Pence truly there's a tyrannical
tendency among religious people and then
they just use Jesus or the Bible as an
excuse now of course none of that is
true the only theocrats the only people
who actually want to rule from above by
instituting their moral preferences on
society from the top down are the folks
on the Left who actually want to invade
rights on a regular basis and force
people to do things that they don't want
to do so a lot more common on the left
than it is on the right so they're
actually using their own theocratic
tendencies toward government which a lot
of folks on the radical left see is a
quasi godlike figure that are using that
own theocratic tendency and then they're
projecting it on to people like Mike
Pence it's really quite disgusting this
is the part where I become rather
perturbed when people suggest that the
the evils of Western civilization are
unique while the goods are universal
this is this is the part of the argument
I've never understood from people who
are highly critical of Western
civilization they point out correctly
that Western civilization has been
responsible for an immense amount of
evil there's tremendous racism endemic
in Western civilization there's there's
religious persecution obviously there's
genocide against you know my extended
family I mean this sort of stuff was
part of Western civilization it is but
here's what makes Western civilization
different all of those things exist in
virtually every other culture throughout
the vast span of time the good stuff is
the part that we don't have a really
good explanation for the good stuff is
the part where we have to say okay what
drove all the good stuff to happen
because any secular values that we all
hold dear things like freedom of speech
and free markets are actually rooted in
judeo-christian values about the fact
that we are all made in God's image that
we are individuals with creative
capacity that the universe is an
understandable place where we ought to
be able to use reason these are
religious assumptions these are not
assumptions you can make if you are a
scientific materialist
those are religiously based but
making those assumptions now you have to
make a secular argument for why public
policy ought to prevail along some lines
or other lines but the assumptions that
you make from the outset are very rarely
based in simple evidence assumptions
that you make politically or values wise
are generally based in a religious
underpinning which is why when I debated
Sam Harrison I asked him you know why do
you think our values are so similar even
though you're a militant atheist and I'm
an Orthodox Jew the answer is because we
grew up in a judeo-christian society
with 3,000 years of common history 10
miles from each other
Taisha a little bit towards the end of
your lecture but if you could describe
more I guess like elaborate more on what
you mean by decency and and these these
fundamental values especially in light
of the statements that you've just made
in response to the question not this
last question but before this
recognizing the fluidity of culture and
cultural values and the existence of
cultures that don't necessarily share
the same values I mean religious on you
but leaving aside the religious aspects
of the Ten Commandments I think that'd
be a pretty good place to start with
basic decency I think that you know
basic values that we all that we in
Western civilization tend to share are
things like you don't get to kill people
you don't get to kidnap people I think
that the values that have developed
later anti-slavery values for example
that are a later breaking development
from Western civilization you know but
have roots in judeo-christian
civilization those are values that that
are fundamental values of decency the
the ones embodied in the in the in the
Constitution seem to me to be good
values like I don't get to harm you
because I don't get to use the
government as a club against you because
I disagree with what you say I don't get
to use the government as a club against
you because I disagree with your
religious practice that doesn't infringe
on me I have sort of a John Stuart Mill
view of interpersonal decency when it
comes to governmental intervention and
that is I get to wave my fist around as
much as I want so long as it doesn't hit
your face now what I think that some
people get dicey about this I don't want
to lead you here but I think this is
where some people get dicey about this
idea is they say okay well what about
the things where I'm waving my fists
around and I'm not formally hitting you
in the face but you're but you're
getting me upset so for example if you
have a private business and the private
business decides to discriminate against
Jews already decides to discriminate
against Blacks or against gays right is
that what would you do about that
so I don't think the government has any
business telling private businesses what
to do because I think the capitalism is
colorblind and that means that if
somebody discriminates against Jews or
blacks or gays they'll go out of
business there will be other people who
offer their
I think it's important to recognize that
that tension is important and I think
that when we try to remove the sources
of tension by either removing reason on
the one hand or religion on the other
hand you end up in a bad place but
that's not to say that that the tension
is constant or that it is constantly at
the same pitch and think of a rubber
band that is sort of you know shrinking
and growing and shrinking and growing
there may be an ideal point of tension
and that ideal points of tension builds
a bridge that is strong enough to allow
us to build a civilization on top of it
the point is that that tension can be
very easily lost by weakening either
religion too much or reason too much if
you imagine civilization as a suspension
bridge if he starts a week in one side
of the suspension bridge either side
then it can collapse and if you
strengthen one side too much then the
bridge is going to pull apart and places
and the entire structure is going to
fall visit civilization in other words
is delicate and the the delicacy of
civilization requires us to be in
constant maintenance of both our region
of both our reason and and our religious
conviction is about the nature of the
world and human life if you read the
Declaration of Independence everything
that I am saying is deeply embedded in
the words of the Declaration of
Independence the notion of all human
beings having equal rights and
independence sprang originally from that
biblical judeo-christian notion of man
being made in God's image ad mixed with
the Greek tradition of individual reason
passed down generation after generation
transmuted over time into the
understanding that not only our human
beings made in God's image with will and
reason but we have a right we have a
natural rights we have a Liberty to
exercise that reason because otherwise
we can't fulfill what God wants of us
the founders despite the common
misperception that they were a bunch of
atheists theists that they knew all of
this stuff Washington famously said the
foundation of our national policy will
be laid and the pure and immutable
principles of private morality there
exists in the economy and course of
nature an indissoluble union between
virtue and happiness and this is the
America is the place where all of this
came together those are the principles
in the Declaration of Independence those
are the principles in the Constitution
have we been perfect in our application
of those principles of course not
but the goal of America is to live up to
those principles not to discard those
principles and here's where we get into
the difficulties with today because on
the one hand there are a lot of folks
who have decided they want to discard
Jerusalem and on the other you have a
bunch of folks who have decided they
want to discard
a bunch of folks who believe that
religion is bad religion is terrible
religion is repressive religion is
tyrannical we have to force religious
people to violate their own precepts in
their business practices if people if
kids are taught religion then they are
being perverted against the common good
but here's the truth without religion
there is no free will and there is no
reason you cannot make the argument that
human beings are capable of making
freely will decisions in a universe
where human beings are a bunch of are a
set of firing neurons and a ball of meat
wandering through the universe being a
secular materialist does not give you
freedom it chains you to your biology we
live in the most prosperous time in
human history at a time when a baby born
can expect to live past the Year eighty
a time when virtually no one is living
in starvation conditions in the West
when virtually everybody can expect to
have a long healthy life when racial
tolerance is at an all-time high when
freedom is at an all-time high so how
did things get so good how did we end up
here because two centuries ago everybody
was dying in nasty brutish and short
fashion so what exactly changed is
question number one and number two is
why are we so angry to each other amidst
the most glorious conditions ever lived
in by any human beings at any time and
the answer is we have to investigate the
roots of our civilization and those
foundations I contend in the right side
of history lie one in judeo-christian
ethics and to lie in Greek teleology the
idea that we can apply reason to the
universe and come up with good moral
answers and scientific answers to the
conditions that surround us so that
combination the push and pull between
human reason and divine revelation that
that push and pull created the West we
have tried forcibly in many cases to
undermine both of those bases for
Western civilization then were surprised
when we return to the chaos that
preceded them the judeo-christian
tradition teaches that God created an
ordered universe and that we have an
obligation to try to make the world
better this offers us purpose and
suggests that history moves forward
judeo-christian tradition teaches that
every human is created in the image of
God that is each individual's life is
infinitely valuable this seems
self-evident to us now but only because
we have lived with this belief for so
long the far more natural belief is that
the strong should subjugate the weak
which is
nicely what people did in nearly every
society in all of history only by
recognizing the divine and others did we
ever move beyond this amoral thinking
toward the concern for human rights
democracy and free enterprise that
characterized the West but
judeo-christian religion alone didn't
build our modern civilization we also
required Greek reason to teach us
objective observation that man has the
capacity to search beyond Revelation for
answers
Greek reason brought us the notion of
the natural law the idea that we could
discover the natural purpose the Telos
of everything in creation by looking to
its character human beings were created
with the unique capacity to reason
therefore our Telos was to reason the
founding fathers took the best of the
European enlightenment with its roots in
Greek thought and the best of
judeo-christian practice with its roots
in the Bible and melded them into a
whole new political philosophy without
judeo-christian values we fall into
scientific materialism the belief that
physical matter is the only reality and
therefore also fall into nihilism the
belief that life has no meaning that we
are merely stellar dust in a cold
universe without Greek reason we fall
into fanaticism the belief that
fundamentalist adherence to unprovable
principles represents the only path
toward meaning the Soviet Union
Communist China and other socialist
tyrannies rejected faith and murdered
100 million people in the 20th century
much of the modern Muslim world has
embraced faith but rejected reason it's
noteworthy that when the Muslim world
did embrace Greek reason from the 8th to
the 14th centuries it was a leading
center for scientific advancement so
again we need both Jerusalem and Athens
revelation and reason
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest-growing
conservative media outlets in the
country if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a like and subscribe to
our YouTube channel so you don't miss
out on any of our content